>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Please welcome James McBride.
[ Applause ]
>> James McBride: You like me,
you really like me [laughter].
Thank you.
So nice to see so many
white people --
I mean, nice people
here today [laughter].
It's just wonderful.
I should say that one of the people
who brought this National
Book Festival back was --
that is rarely mentioned when
talking about how we got here,
is Laura Bush [assumed
spelling] so [applause].
Let it be known that a librarian
is -- brought us together.
And with that her party return
to its former glamor
someday soon [laughter].
And I ain't kidding.
In any case, I want to talk
for another four or five hours
about my new book [laughter]
that nobody read,
and then I'll talk
about the [inaudible].
I'll spend a few minutes.
Is the timekeeper nearby?
Okay, I'm going to spend like the
first five, eight minutes talking
about the James Brown book and
then I'll talk about The Color
of Water and, you know,
The Good Lord Bird,
and then I'll open
the floor to questions
because I know I don't
have a lot of time.
So a few years ago, well
not too long, my mother died
in 2010, January 9, 2010.
And six months later my
ex-wife, at the time was my wife,
decided that she no longer
wanted to be married to moi.
So that painful episode was quite --
was really quite costly
in many ways,
particularly financially [laughter].
So -- well, emotionally as
well, no kidding, you know,
cross my heart, hope to die.
But, so what happened was, you know,
I was working on the John Brown book
at the time and I call a
call from somebody who was
from James Brown's family.
Essentially I got a call from a
guy who knew a guy who knew a guy,
and ended up meeting, you
know, a couple members
of James Brown's family
who basically just begged
me to take on this book.
And I first turned it down.
I said, it's just too much trouble
because James Brown left all
of his money, his worth was between
100 and $150 million, he left it all
to educate poor black
and white children
in South Carolina and Georgia.
That was 10 years ago [applause].
Well, you know, now you can
start crying after applauding,
because to that -- since -- that
was 10 years ago, December 25, 2006,
and more than 10 years
ago that happened.
He laid his will out and
to date not a single dime
of that has gone to a single kid.
And that's because his will has been
tied up in court in South Carolina,
which is like a different
country really [laughter].
And so one of his relatives
really wanted to spring that out.
They wanted free that money up to
-- essentially it was oldest son,
Terry, and his grandson, Forlando,
and so they asked me to take it on.
At first I turned it down
and then I later agreed
to do it, and so I took it on.
But what happened was I spent, you
know, I don't know, two and a half,
almost three years fooling
around in South Carolina.
It was very difficult because first
of all many books have been
written about James Brown.
And, secondly, James
Brown is a very, very --
he is absolutely impossible
categorize for a lot reasons.
But his life really is a metaphor
for how we can handle race
in America and why
we can't get along.
Because here's a guy
who during the course
of his life really
revolutionized American music.
And I'll just give you a
crash, sort of a cheap example
that musicians will
say, this is horrible.
But this is the blues.
Blues goes like this [musical
sounds] one chord [musical sounds]
one chord, then you go to the
fourth chord [musical sounds],
the fourth chord [musical
sounds], then you go back
to the one chord [musical sounds],
and guess you go to the five,
then you go to the fourth, then
you go to the one [musical sounds]
and then you do it again, right.
Well, when you sing the blues --
when you play the blues
drummers play --
you know, if you're just
playing fatback 1950 blues,
you're playing -- the drummer
is playing the hit two and four,
he's going [musical sounds] and
he's playing that hit like that.
What James Brown did in his
music was that instead of going
to the one, four, five,
which he did in altered tones
and in altered time, thanks to Pee
Wee Ellis and Fred Wesley and some
of his other musicians,
including Maceo Parker's brother,
who teaches here in Washington,
D. I can't remember his name.
But what he did was that he
started creating music with --
instead of the beat laying
on the two and the four,
it would fall on the one of the
third bar, so it would go --
[ Musical Sounds ]
And so that sort of rise and lilt
was actually previously unknown
in the R and B world.
And it sounds like a small
thing, but I remember when one
of the great jazz drummers
that played Charlie Parker went
to South Africa --
went to [inaudible].
I heard this story from
the [inaudible] musician.
I can't remember the drummer's name.
He's still alive.
But he went to play and he was
playing with an African troop,
and there was an, you know,
African troop like 10, 12 drummers
and they were playing together and
they were going [musical sounds],
and this guy had his
set out, and this is one
of the greatest jazz drummers.
I can't remember his
name at the moment
because there's so many of you here.
But -- and so the leader
nodded to him
to tell him to come in on the one.
And this guy, he was listening and
three times he tried to come in
and the third he just couldn't
so he threw his sticks up
and laughed and just got up.
And the drummer, the leader
drummer said, you know,
he motioned to the drummers
and he backed them off
and they showed him
where the one was.
And then he got in to where
the one was, he just went crazy
because he found this freedom
in the sophisticated syncopation
of what African drummers
are capable of doing.
What James Brown did was
he managed to take his --
the business of rhythm -- not James
Brown, James Brown and the musicians
in his band, most of whom by
the way were from the south,
they took this confined element
of the one, four, five blues
and using just the one chord,
staying on the one chord,
they found ways to create a rhythm
that we still here
today in hip hop music.
Another one who did it to great
effect was Grover Washington Junior.
When you hear this [musical sounds]
that was created by a saxophonist
by Philadelphia named
Grover Washington Junior.
But it wasn't as widespread as James
Brown's music, but it's still heard
in a lot of hip hop music.
And to show you how
advanced James Brown was
and to show you how much
musicians really respected him,
I asked Grover -- because I
worked with Grover Washington
on a couple songs, I played piano
in a couple of songs in the studio,
and I asked him, I said, how come
you never played with James Brown?
Because Grover is a
funky saxophone player.
He said, he laughed.
He said, James Brown, he said I
wasn't funky enough [laughter].
And Grover Washington, of
course, was plenty funky.
But James Brown's musicians
created a sound that is --
that is now known, you
know, around the world.
And the irony is that James
Brown never even made the cover
of Rolling Stone Magazine
until he died.
He was always seen as like the
scream at the end of the dial.
But his music accomplished
everything.
He recorded with Alva Nelson,
who was a pioneer jazz arranger.
He recorded jazz songs, blues.
His career encompassed the entire --
a gigantic spectrum of musical life.
And so his catalogue is
worth a lot of money.
But, unfortunately, his
personal life was a shambles.
And for that reason his will and
his estate has been tied up in court
in South Carolina for 10 years.
And ironically the only
person that has been following
up James Brown's will and -- will
and his estate, and you can read all
about it, is a 63 year old,
white grandmother from Newberry,
South Carolina named Sue Summer.
And the authorities down there,
and when I say the authorities,
the lawyers, the [inaudible]
of powerful attorneys,
including the attorney general and
the other judges that are involved,
they all have a little hand in
this, because it's all, you know,
I give you a little,
you give me a little.
You know how it works.
This is Washington, D.C. They
tried to lock her up twice.
You know, the freedom -- she drops
a lawsuit for freedom of information
and they try to get her
notes and they've threatened
to put her in jail two times.
One time they delivered a subpoena
while she was putting her two year
old grandmother --
grandchild to sleep.
And so that's -- you know, what
really needs to happen in the case
of James Brown is that
the Department of Justice,
or some federal agency, needs to
move into South Carolina and say,
this is what the guy wanted
and why is it not happening?
And if that doesn't happen
it's just going to continue
because it's a gigantic
cow that can be milked.
They're just milking the estate.
They drop a law -- this
one has to read the book.
He's charging because
he's got to read the books
on James Brown so he charge.
This one he -- they need to analyze
this so they get this law firm.
And it's just -- it changed my
perspective about the world.
You know, my mother was -- my mother
was a person who really marveled
at stuff that was -- that was
like -- that she would marvel,
because she really -- like she
really enjoyed having a car.
She just thought that was
like the coolest thing.
Like if you just give her a
new car there's nothing --
you know, when The Color of Water
became a big success I just bought
her a car and she thought
that I had just
like given her the
United States treasury.
Really. But she had -- you know,
she had this innocence and a quality
of wonder about things that
all of her children had.
And it's in part because I
did this James Brown book.
It robbed me of that
sparkle for a while.
It's come back now, only
because I haven't read the book
and I don't look at
it no more [laughter].
But it's hard to think that
people will allow such --
you know, such depravity to go on.
Just, you know, guys in
suits with nice shoes
and ties just ripping this guy off.
It's just -- it's terrible.
And the irony is that the children
of South Carolina are among
the poorest in this country.
The other thing to remember is
that James Brown really
is not so much a child.
You know, he's portrayed in the
media as a guy who grew up in --
you know, if you saw that movie
which was about 40% fiction,
you know, he grew up in a cabin
and, you know, I'm a little bit done
with the whole business of black
folks, or poor white folks growing
up in cabins and just sitting
there, you know, holding --
eating grits and I mean
[inaudible], you know.
Aren't some of them shy or some of
them are allergic to this or that
or the other, and some of them --
don't the brother pick
on the sister.
I mean aren't they
normal to some degree?
Please. Well, what happened with
James Brown was his family was
from a section of South
Carolina called -- where the --
where the federal government,
along with GE and General --
GE and Dupont Company decided
to create something called the
Savannah River nuclear site.
And what they did was they chose
an area where there was a river,
where there was -- where there
were not a lot of people with power
and they just simply moved six
towns, 300 square miles of area.
They just made all the people move
and they created the Savannah
River nuclear site, which is really
where they create bombs,
where they process plutonium
and uranium to make nuclear bombs.
And that's how James
Brown became displaced.
So when you see him in the cabin
in the woods he was in the cabin
in the woods because his family
was a family of sharecroppers
that had lived there
for several generations.
That entire area of all those poor
people, including white farmers
and businesses and hundreds and
dozens -- hundreds of businesses,
post offices, schools,
everything, they were moved.
And this happened in 1951.
And while there's record of
-- in fact, Look Magazine --
Life Magazine bit off
a really telling --
you know, touching story about
a school teacher who's class had
to move, building moved,
and children watched it go,
and they swore they were -- you
know, they were staying there.
Their grandfather was
buried there and so forth.
There wasn't a peep of a noise
made about 8000 some odd share --
black sharecroppers
who were displaced.
And they -- the majority of
people who were displaced
by this nuclear -- this nuclear bomb
making facility were poor blacks
from that area, and James
Brown's family was among them.
So in many ways he's a
child of the nuclear age.
And then, of course,
he became a great star
and he created this
revolutionary sounds.
And that's it.
And the book is basically my journey
to discover James Brown in a way
that people haven't done before.
So it's not a biography like, you
know, how you go to the book store
and you read a biography
and then you go to the back
to see how the guy died [laughter]?
It's not one of those
types of books.
Basically I talked to people
who knew him very well
and show the world from their
perspective, like Miss Emma --
Miss Emma Austin who knew James
Brown for 40 some odd years.
And these -- I'm talking
about bright,
deep people who really understood
him, Sue Summer, of course,
Mr. Charles Bobbit, who was --
managed James Brown for years
and also managed Michael Jackson.
And, of course, Pee Wee Ellis.
Pee Wee Ellis is the guy
who wrote Cold Sweat.
He wrote a lot of jazz standards.
For those of you who
are jazz musicians,
if you know who Jaco
Pastorius is, a bassist.
Jaco Pastorius has a really
famous song called Chicken,
which everybody thinks
Jaco Pastorius wrote
but he did not write it.
Pee Wee Ellis wrote it.
Pee Wee Ellis is an extraordinarily
gifted tenor saxophonist,
who studied with Sonny Rollins
and entered James Brown's
band in around 1964.
And if you hear James Brown's
music after 1964 that's
where he makes this big evolution.
And that's because James Brown
would go into his rehearsal
and he would say, [inaudible]
I want to do that like that.
And Pee Wee would just
translate it to the musicians.
You know, when I was a kid we
used to make fun of James Brown.
You know, I'll be James
Brown, you be the translator.
[inaudible].
James Brown said that
you have to go over
and give me some --
[inaudible] [laughter].
But he was enormously talented.
He was a great artist.
And we forgive a lot of our artists
for what they do, but we can't seem
to forgive James Brown
for what he's done.
Because his marriages were a mess.
At the end of his life he had drug
-- you know, the guy never did drugs
or drank or smoked most of his life.
And at the end of his life
he did all of those things.
He certainly did drugs.
And the reason why
is because he saw --
he had seen that he just
destroyed so much that --
behind him, and he wanted
so much for his community.
This is a guy who lived, you know,
10 miles from where he
was born after he died.
When James Brown died
he could see the towers
of the Savannah River nuclear
site from his front porch.
And he used to tell Charles Bobbit,
his manager, he said, you know,
look at the -- you see
them towers, Mr. Bobbit,
he said, that's the government.
They're listening to me.
They're listening through my teeth.
You know, he lost his touch
with reality in so many ways.
But at bottom, despite the fact that
his band disliked him intensely,
and despite the fact that he did not
love women, James Brown loved music.
He didn't love women at all.
He wasn't capable of
truly loving a woman.
Despite all that, I don't know of
any other star that I can think
of that has left every penny he
made to educate poor children
in his state and the
neighboring state.
That's a very unusual thing.
And it's because he felt
at the end of his life
that we had not finished
the job, and frankly you
and I know that he's right.
So from -- on that somber note, I'll
now tell you some Milton Berle jokes
and we'll just all [laughter].
No, are we passed the eight
minute mark or whatever?
Oh, the timekeeper was
hypnotized [laughter].
She just -- well, a few notes
about The Good Lord Bird.
The Color of Water, first.
I explained to you that
my mother died in 2010.
She lived a very good life.
She was 88 years old.
You know, she died at home.
She waited until my -- all
the kids came before she died.
Like my brother, Hunter,
had just gotten married.
She waited for him to get married
and he went -- he got married.
He went to Puerto Rico or something
like that and she, you know,
it was clear that she was dying.
And so she waited until he
came back home and he saw her
and then she passed away.
She was actually -- I mean,
she was -- she was pretty --
she was planning to see that
movie, what's that movie --
what's that movie with the
cartoons, the cartoon characters
and the real characters together?
It begins with an a.
[inaudible]
Huh?
[ Inaudible ]
No, not Roger Rabbit.
Yeah [laughter].
No, it's some movie.
She was --
[ Inaudible ]
Avatar. Yeah, she was planning to
see Avatar like the week she died.
Like, she was like, well,
we're going to go see Avatar.
I'm like, I don't think so mom.
But, you know, it was --
it was horribly difficult.
She's buried in North Carolina
in the colored cemetery there
because when my father
and my grandparents got buried they
were buried in the colored cemetery,
which is now closed to,
you know, to all newcomers.
So even in death my mother was
like, you know, she integrated.
She's like the only white
person there [laughter].
I was like, oh boy.
But, you know, when I
pulled up to that cemetery
and I saw her coffin I just
-- it was like surreal.
I said, this is not really,
you know -- but it was real.
But I'm grateful to her.
And, you know, it's
funny because yesterday,
or Thursday I got the
National Medal of --
National Humanities Medal from
President Obama [inaudible].
I got it from him so [applause].
Well, I didn't mention it
so you could, you know,
I mean there's a lot of
people who are more qualified.
But, you know, they called me.
I said, okay, I'll take it.
But I was -- you know, I was
sitting like right in the front
and I saw him talking and I said --
I said to myself, I wish my
mother could see this, you know.
And I bet you -- I said to
myself, I bet you he says
that every once in
a while, you know.
He's a gracious dude, man.
He knows -- you could see
like when he did it --
you could see he does this a lot,
but that he gets a little pleasure
out of doing it every time.
I know politicians are very skilled
at saying, hey, how's the kids?
But you can see he really enjoys it.
And people just -- they just -- they
just love him in the White House.
I mean, they really respect him.
And we're going to -- you
know, we're not going to miss
because he said himself,
I'm not going anywhere.
You know, the world's not going
to end after November 9, you know,
unless Donald Trump wins.
But, you know, I really
feel [laughter].
No, I'm just -- I'm just kidding,
I'm just kidding [laughter].
Look, I just finished reading
William Shirer's book, The Rise
and Fall of the Third
Reich, and the parallels
between Adolf Hitler's rise
and Donald Trump's rise
are truly disturbing.
William Shirer was a truly
good -- really great writer.
And by the way, for those of you
who are interested in writing,
he wasn't really -- he
was a radio reporter.
But the reason why the book is so
good in part is because, I mean,
it takes the linear approach to
the -- you know, to this event,
to this -- you know, to this
evil genius, but it also --
the reporting is so deep.
The reporting on the
book is so deep.
Moving to The Good Lord Bird,
I must have read maybe 25
books about John Brown.
I initially wanted to write
a book about Abraham Lincoln.
But then, you know, I just
-- I just couldn't do it.
I mean, it's been done
so well before, you know.
And then I wanted to write
about slavery in a way
that made people laugh and that
brought -- because, you know,
Americans are very funny people.
Like we're really good people.
I mean, I know all of you ain't,
but most of you [laughter]
are very, very good people.
No, but we like to -- I wanted
to write about slavery in a way
that would show people what it
was like without making them feel
like they're taking their medicine.
Because every time I read one
of these books about, you know,
what happens in -- not every time
but, you know, you read these books
about black history and you go,
I know what's going to happen.
You know, why do I not care?
Let me see.
You know, did the Knick's win?
I mean, because you know -- you
know, you kind of know what --
and that's not really a way to
tell a story, because what you have
to really tell is like,
okay, the Iraq war went on.
We were all here.
Everybody was here when all this --
you know, when all this heavy
policing business went on.
And, you know, you [inaudible]
and the yellow journalism,
you have to salute the flag
and pretend you -- you know.
How many people actually
stood up and said, you know?
I mean, Terry Gross
-- other than Terry?
How many people other than
Terry Gross said, you know?
So I wanted to write a book to
show people how powerful slavery is
and how slavery makes
slaves of us all.
One of the good things about
this era in which we live is
that white people have finally come
to the realization, many, not all
but many have come
to the realization
that if we don't solve this
problem of racism we really are
in for -- in for a long day.
I remember when I was in college
we'd have these talks about racism.
We'd meet about something and
it would be like eight blacks,
two whites, and we'd have a
long talk and then everyone,
but now it's not that way.
Now more white people are
seeing what the deal is.
In any case, the only reason
I wrote about John Brown's --
you know, I wrote the book,
create a create of the onion was
because I didn't think I could
write about a girl really.
I just didn't feel
qualified to write about it
from a girl's perspective.
So I said, well, if
it's a boy pretending
to be a girl then I won't
look so bad [laughter].
So I did that.
And then I just -- I love
what John Brown tried to do.
I love it when someone stands up
and says this is what I represent.
And it's really -- you know, it
was beyond malevolence for him.
He really felt in his heart
that black people were equal.
And, you know, that really
must have made him seem crazy.
And the historians who have
written about the period,
at least until the
last 10 years or so,
treated John Brown
like he was crazy.
And he was probably was a little
bit dysfunctional or had some sort
of schizophrenia, you
know, something.
We all got a little taste
of something [laughter].
So anyway, I just wanted
to make it funny.
And I'm so glad that
it reached people.
And it's just been a delight.
It's been a really nice ride.
Well, we have to open the
floor to questions now.
So, you know, feel
free to ask questions.
And, if you have them, you know,
you can ask any question you want.
You know, I'll be happy to try
to answer any questions you have.
IS that the mic guy
or a question guy?
Okay, okay.
Yes? You have a question?
Oh okay. Well, all right, you
go ahead and I'll repeat it.
[ Inaudible ]
Okay, the question was, James
Brown was an entrepreneur.
He had a radio station
and knew a lot about that.
He was an entrepreneur, but
he wasn't a very good one.
He had three radio stations,
one in Baltimore and two in --
one in Augusta and one
I think in Tennessee.
But he really wasn't that
good of a businessman.
He didn't know how
to run a business.
He didn't know how to
delegate authority.
So, and he wasn't a
great businessman.
Yes?
>> Hi, I was going to ask
you to speak a little bit
about how you came to
write Song Yet Sung.
>> James McBride: Okay.
>> And who are some of
your favorite writers?
>> James McBride: Okay, well --
>> Two questions.
>> James McBride: I wrote
Song Yet Sung because I was --
became a fan of Harriet Tubman
and wanted to dramatize her life
in a way that was -- I
thought was interesting.
And also, I wanted to -- I wanted
to kind of have a perspective
of if a slave woke up now and
heard some of the violence
in today's hip hop music,
so called hip hop music,
what would he or she think?
So that kind was -- that
was the impetus to do it.
Some of my favorite writers are the
normal ones, you know, Toni Morrison
and Faulkner and all
the -- I read everybody.
I read a lot of history books.
Leon Litwack is a favorite of mine.
He wrote Been in the Storm so Long
and, I think, Trouble in Mind.
I just told you about
William Shirer.
I read mostly history books.
Okay, yes, next question.
>> First of all I just want to
thank you for The Color of Water.
It was very impactful for me in
my life and I want to thank you
for telling your story to us.
Secondly, I didn't know
a lot about James Brown.
But as you're talking it reminded me
of having read Charles
Dickens' The Bleak House.
>> James McBride: Uh-huh.
>> And also Franz Kafka's The Trial.
And I'm wondering trying to
connect these different worlds
and different periods of history
whether there's some universal link
between what James Brown went
through and is going through now
with his estate and what it
tells us about human nature?
I just throw it out there because as
you're talking about it, it just --
you know, things were
going off in my head.
So --
>> James McBride: Well.
>> What do you think
James Brown's experience
with his estate tells us
about our human nature?
>> James McBride: That's
a very good question.
We, as a society that have --
we have become so litigious.
Is that the right word?
>> Yeah.
>>
>> James McBride: Sorry,
attorneys here, I know a third
of you are attorneys and I
truly apologize [laughter].
I am not trying to --
everything I say I don't mean
and I take it back before
I say it [laughter].
But what happened -- what has
happened is that we are society
where -- look, in a society where
you rob people of their culture,
when you take people's cultural
richness and then sell cereal
with it and beer and soft drinks
to make money, the result is going
to be happened to James
Brown's estate.
Where people try to sue us so they
can get a new car and better house.
And, I mean, it's part
in parcel for a life
that happens in the music business.
I covered Michael Jackson in 1984
when he was doing his victory tour.
We came here.
We came to Robert Kennedy Stadium.
Man, you should have seen
him dance in those --
I mean, he was just unconscious.
And he was surrounded by a bunch
of, you know, people who were --
just didn't care about
him, you know.
People cared -- Don
King was one of those
who sucked off the
cow in those days.
The only one who cared about
him really were his brothers
and his mother.
I have tremendous respect
for Michael Jackson's mother.
I don't talk about her
publicly, but Mrs. --
Katherine is a very good mother.
She raised, what, 10 kids in
Hollywood and they stuck together.
I think she did a very good job.
So the short answer to the
young lady's question is,
and she's very young,
you're young, you are young,
is that people will do evil things.
I think it's not so much what people
do, it's our response to their evil
that counts because
we can't control them.
I hope that answers your
question at least a little bit.
Yes?
>> Okay, hi, I'm Naomi
[assumed spelling]
and I want -- I have two questions.
The first is your mom was a --
I don't think she was a Holocaust
survivor but she came from that part
of the world that was
persecuted, right?
>> James McBride: Yeah.
>> And I know that she converted.
>> James McBride: Right.
>> You had a great book.
My mom loves that book.
My mom is a Holocaust survivor,
and I wanted to thank you for that.
But did she at all identify
herself with being Jewish
or formally Jewish, or did she just
basically pack that away and --
>> James McBride: Well, you know,
you said identify yourself with --
it's not a real easy word to
really -- you know, what's Jew?
You know. What's black?
I think -- I'll put it this way.
When my mother converted
Christianity she thought she had
walked away from Judaism forever.
And in many ways she had.
She never turned back.
But then on the other hand,
my sisters, a couple of them,
were interested in Judaism.
She encouraged them
to study Judaism.
And my -- a couple of
my nephews as well.
She said, look, it didn't work for
me but it's a beautiful religion.
That's about as close -- I mean, she
got -- she got to know her sister.
She came -- she came
full circle in terms
of her bitterness towards Judaism
because she saw it through the prism
of her father's brutality.
But me, personally,
just so you know,
I really couldn't care less
which religion you are.
I mean, I was raised in the
Baptist Church and I, you know --
but you won't see me
going to see, you know,
some of these maker preachers
taking poor people's money
like some of these numbskulls.
You won't see me doing that.
I think if a person is a
Muslim or Hindu or Buddhist,
it's all the same, you know.
Love somebody, it doesn't
really matter.
If you're -- listen, religion
is ripping us apart now.
It's ripping the world apart,
because people run around claiming
to be Muslim and they're not
Muslims, they claim to be Muslims,
are murdering innocent people.
John Brown was a Christian.
He claimed he was a Christian, and
some people called him a terrorist.
But he didn't kill
innocent children.
He fought people who were his size.
So we have to be careful with
this whole business of religion.
You can't use it as a baseball bat.
But it was a very good question,
madam, and I hope I answered it.
>> The one I really want
to ask you about was --
>> One question.
>> Song Yet Sung.
Can I ask you one question
about that?
>> James McBride: Go ahead.
>> Thank you.
You did a lot of your
research in Dorchester County
and I did the whole Underground
Railroad tour and it was amazing.
I have a place on Tilghman Island.
Were you able to get there?
>> James McBride: Yeah, I
got to Tilghman Island, yeah.
You know, very nice,
very nice [laughter].
Yeah, you know, I never saw that
area from the prism of today,
I always saw it from
the prism of 1850 so --
but I did see, I did enjoy it.
Very beautiful area.
Should I go to that side now?
Go ahead, please.
>> Hi, I recently read The
Good Lord Bird for a book club
and I was actually very
surprised by how funny it was.
And I wanted to thank you for that
because I think it made the reading
experience much more enjoyable
for me.
It's a very heavy topic, of
course, but I think the little bits
of humor really sort of, you
know, it helped to tell it
in a way I thought that
was new and different.
But I will say it made
a lot of the members
of my book club very
uncomfortable in some areas,
particularly with the Frederick
Douglass [inaudible] but,
you know --
>> James McBride: Well, I had --
I just -- it was just so funny.
That's the only reason
I made Frederick --
the Frederick Douglass thing
[inaudible] it was just so funny.
I couldn't -- I couldn't
resist [laughter].
>> Well my question is,
you talked about Onion,
which of course is our
main character in the book,
and Onion is a boy who's
mistaken as a girl and you talked
about not feeling qualified
to tell the story
from the perspective of a girl.
And I wonder why you were
interested in telling it
from that perspective to begin with?
What was sort of your
thinking behind it?
>> James McBride: Oh, well,
that's a good question.
Because during slavery, and even now
in American society, black women,
they live in a place that is
-- they're like dinosaurs.
They walk alone.
They're really at the
bottom of everything.
I mean, I'm not trying to put words
into the mouth of black women here,
so if I say it wrong, I
truly apologize [inaudible].
But -- so I wanted the world of
slavery seen from the prism of a --
of a little black girl,
because they were the ones
who were the least powerful.
But I didn't feel qualified
to write about it.
Like, you know, I don't
know how to do hair.
I don't understand -- I don't
understand the power of hair
and how you look, you know.
As you can see, what does
hair mean to me [laughter]?
Hair means nothing to
me, nothing my friend.
So that's why I -- that's
why I chose that approach.
Yes?
>> I, too, am from
[inaudible] County
and your synopsis was very succinct
regarding the Savannah River site
and all the other things
going on there.
My question to you
has to do with your --
I guess your reading history.
Are there particular books
that influenced you and,
if so, in what way or how?
Is there a particular
book or books that stand
out in your mind, thank
you, as a reader?
>> James McBride: Okay, that's a
good -- that's a good question.
Not really [laughter].
No, only because I read so much.
And everything -- I can generally
remember the last thing I ever read,
you know, which in this case was
the -- William Shirer's book.
You learn when you're a writer,
and you've been a journalist,
that you have to read between
the lines and that there's no
such thing as real subjectivity.
Even William Shirer's book kind of
short shrifts the whole business
of what was happening to the
Jews during Hitler's rise,
because Hitler was
brutal towards the Jews
from the very beginning [inaudible].
And he -- and I don't know really
what his true response to it was
when he was in Berlin, because I
just have a hard time believing
anybody who walking around
Berlin did not see the brutality
that was happening
to the Jews there.
So you learn to read
between the lines.
That's the short answer
to your question.
But I don't have a specific
book that -- I do --
some of the William
Still slave narratives --
some of the slave narratives in --
from William Still still
sticks in my heart.
You know, the first person
that counts is slaves,
African Americans talking
about this,
the lives of slaves
stick in my heart.
But no specific book.
Did that answer your question?
>> Yes, I guess at the heart
I'm curious why you decided
to become an author?
What [inaudible]?
>> James McBride: Go to the
mic, I'm sorry I can't hear you.
>> Sorry, I guess I'm curious
as to what drove you to write?
I mean, what was it
that made you so --
>> James McBride: That
particular book or in general?
>> In general?
>> James McBride: Well,
let me think now.
What drives me to write?
Let's see [laughter].
I don't know.
It's a very difficult question.
[ Laughter ]
Very tough, very difficult question.
Try to [swooshing noise].
Look, you know, when I was working
as a journalist I used to say
to myself, I can't tell
the whole story here.
You know, you go -- my first -- one
of my first stories was about --
was about a warehouse fire
in Wilmington, Delaware.
I was a [inaudible] reporter.
I just finished Columbia
and I went to --
I was a cop report in Wilmington
News Journal and they went me
out to do a fire about --
like just a normal house fire.
You know, and I stood
there with my pad
and I'm watching the
house burn down.
I'm talking to the cops.
Oh man, this is a -- you
know, four -- how many?
Okay, four alarm fire.
And I went back and I wrote like a
10 inch story and I said to myself,
this is not really what happened.
You know, something else happened.
Like maybe the landlord
didn't pay the --
or maybe the tenant just
got drunk, or the --
you know, something
-- there's more here.
And as I got older the
story just kept getting --
I just began to see the stories
getting bigger and bigger
and then there was no creative
way as a journalist to tell it.
And so when I was about maybe 28,
29 years old I was working
at The Post, I quit.
I just quit.
I moved to New York.
I was overwhelmed and
I just played saxophone
and wrote music for nine years.
I played with a, you
know -- I played with --
I wrote songs for Grover Washington,
Anita Baker, and wrote songs
for Barney and I wrote a
couple musicals that failed.
Yeah, I wrote -- I wish I
wrote the I Love You song.
I wouldn't even be here,
okay [laughter] so.
I would not even be here, all right.
But I did not write that.
And then -- and during that
time I wrote The Color of Water.
I wrote it in -- while I was, you
know, playing Jimmy Scott's band
in the back of vans with guys
smoking weed and, you know,
and I never told anybody that
I was writing about my mother.
You know, I never told
anybody I was doing anything.
I just was like so happy to get
the gig I would just be quiet.
And then I -- you know, the
book came out and it just --
it didn't sell right away.
It wasn't like an instant --
in fact, it was reviewed with every
other, you know, poor mix race,
mulatto book that showed
up that month.
You know, Divided Soul,
Bagels and Chicken [laughter],
you know, Color of Water.
It was all this, you know.
But what happened was women
started reading it, you know,
young Jewish women aged like,
you know 20 to 80, young,
and they just started putting it
in their book clubs and then --
you haven't lived until you've been
to like a coffee [inaudible]
book club in Teaneck,
New Jersey [laughter], really.
And they say, let's check his
teeth, let's check his teeth.
Okay [laughter].
Yes, sir?
>> First of all, I'm sorry.
First of all, you are
a mesmerizing speaker,
[inaudible] word mesmerizing.
I tried to take notes.
I just got wrapped up in what you
were saying, but my question is,
as far as I know, in one of
our books, Miracle of Ste.
Anna, was made into a movie.
What did you think of it?
Do you think it was
true to the book?
>> James McBride: Yes,
true as it could be.
I mean, you only have two hours.
In this case two hours and
46 minutes to, you know,
because Spike Lee does
what he feels like doing.
I thought it was pretty true to it.
I'm not one of those
writers that say, you know,
they cut my characters, you know.
I'm so happy they're
doing it that, you know,
I'm not real picky about it.
So I was glad that the movie at
least, you know, reflected --
you know, accurately reflected
the general push of the book.
I was disappointed, of course,
when it was a flop but --
you know, and I'm sure
all of you have seen it.
And I'm glad, I really am.
This is my heart, my heart which
is -- I'm crying, I'm crying.
But -- so it's all right.
I mean, I have the
greatest job in the world.
I mean, you know, I get to
write -- I get to put, you know,
words on the page and people
actually like pay me for it.
So I'm not -- so I
wasn't disappointed.
All righty.
Over here, sir?
>> Yes, thanks very much.
Bringing you back to The
Color of Water and what one
of the previous persons said about
what moved you to write the book,
you just seemed to, a moment ago
saying, you know, I was in New York,
I was playing jazz, and I started
to write this book about my mom.
I don't think there's
a person in this room
who wasn't moved by that book.
So what was it that
moved you to say,
I got to put this down on paper.
I got to tell this story
of my mom and how she --
>> James McBride: That's a
good -- I mean, fair enough.
I -- at one point in New York --
when I was in New York
I was in Fort Greene.
That's one of the great -- you
know, [inaudible] Spike Lee,
these guys were all walking
around, you know, [inaudible],
I didn't know any of
these people by the way.
I've always walked alone [laughter].
But I was teaching
English to Polish refugees
in a place called St. Stanislaus,
which was a Catholic
Church in Williamsburg.
And the guy who ran
it was a Catholic guy.
I forget -- his first
name was Raymond.
I forgot his land name.
And the sister who ran it
was kind enough to hire me.
Now, I went from the Washington
Post from being a star report,
going to the White House, Regan,
you know, writing my little stories,
and then just teaching
-- standing in front
of like 30 students
teaching English.
And these were hardworking Polish
people, really hardworking,
who came to America
fresh off the boat.
You know, that's not -- that's kind
of a pejorative term but, you know,
that's a derogatory way of
describing their journey to America.
But they just arrived.
Most of them were cleaning houses.
Some of them were very educated.
And somehow or another the whole
business of Jewish people came up.
I can't remember, I guess
I was teaching a class,
and the response was, you
know, someone cracked a job
and then it was like -- and I
said to myself like, you know,
what difference does it --
I mean, what -- you know.
And we talked about a little bit,
and I was a little bit disappointed
in some of the responses
to the whole business
of what Jews are supposed to be.
Now this is in 19 what '88 or
'89, and in some ways it was more
of like what was not
said than what was said.
And that got me to
thinking and then I just --
you know, you live in
-- you live in New York.
You see the Hasidic
Jewish community,
which is basically a
very shy group of people.
I mean, they're seen as
like these, you know --
I don't know how people see
the Hasid's in New York.
But, you know, when
someone complains to me
about the Hasidic people buying
a house, buying an apartment,
and breaking it up into apartments,
buying a building and breaking it
up into apartments and
charging you lots of rent,
all of a sudden it's
like a Jewish thing.
Now if a guy from Greece does that,
well he's just a bum landlord.
But I mean most of these
guys, it's not like they're
like Donald Trump ripping
up parts of the city
and like these giant
developers and selling, you know,
apartments on Columbus
Square for 30 million
to some Turk or some Russian.
I mean, they're hustling
and trying to make it.
So I just kind of just
evolved into the sensibility
of what difference does it make?
And then I just started thinking
about maybe I'm thinking this
because I'm Jewish
myself [laughter].
No, I just -- I just started
to come into this sensibility
of what it must be like to be truly
Jewish in New York at that time.
And so I went -- started going
home and talking to my mother
about where she came from.
And she resisted, and the most she
resisted the more curious I became.
And then when I went to Suffolk,
Virginia and heard the old Jews
from Suffolk talk about what
life was for Jews in the 1930's
in Suffolk, I really, really
-- I really came to it.
And I said this journey
is no different
than that of African Americans.
In the skin color, yes, but
the journey is the same.
And it's the journey --
and I'll close by saying
that journey is the same
for Italians, and Irish,
and it's the same for Mexicans,
and Ecuadorians, and Indian people,
Pakistani people, Chinese,
Asian, Korean, it's the same.
And if we are foolish enough
to close our doors to people
who don't look like us, we are
closing the door to tomorrow.
I will close with that [applause].
Thank you very much [applause].
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.